hey Brian gonna I'm gonna go on a bit of
a stroll all right
[Music]
yo I'm rich Brian
jouji and we're celebrating the idiot
rising head in the clouds album and tour
by cooking for our friends at our end of
summer party house
the thing is though I don't think we
really know how to cook welcome to the
feast mansion
welcome to the feast mansion welcome to
the feast mansion welcome to the feast
mansion
[Music]
yo what up this vision Brian this is Joe
J so we're trying to step our game up a
little bit for the party and we're
trying to make like omakase
sushi but we don't know how to do any of
that and so we brought in the legend mr.
yo-yo Takahashi so five things we gotta
break it down fish yeah kind of this
this is a king who is kind of yellowtail
oh yeah
whole fish actually from New Zealand but
you guys never break you know you never
see I did with my hands once the parking
lot did you learn to make sushi in Kyoto
I'm sorry not oh you get yeah well just
cut off the whole skin damn that was
clean alright so we're having a party
can you teach us how to make sushi oh of
course I'm down to a new salmon ha let's
go let's go - no yeah it's the same time
oh this is the ass cuz bigger I've no
idea yeah yeah is this fatter that's
exactly you guys daddy daddy
yeah just follow tonight
yes sir
[Music]
okay that's pretty [ __ ] good oh it's
pretty good when I was younger I wanted
to be a fisherman
that's cute story because I like eating
fish and catching fish oh so I thought
it was yeah I used to be go like a
fishing enough sometimes yeah I used to
go fishing a lot it's all I'm gonna make
this for you guys all right yeah happy
but I bring down the other wasabi
actually Wow okay so check
clap it grab nice yeah and then make
between the rice and use of one finger
oh because that's my little Oh kind of
coupled the stylus to make this I don't
even know what you're doing with your
hair so fast this wow that's some
Rubik's Cube [ __ ] I'm gonna try it
I'll give it a try okay hold it
grab a nice yeah throw in the glass or
you can go straight like this oh they'll
hold it feels like watching you build
the IKEA bucks is gonna be really hard
and I'm gonna mess it
from told yes hold okay we've butchered
this profession dude Action Bronson we
beat my ass range yeah I see this would
be like [ __ ] that's not so we mastered
the nigiri but we got to fill out that
platter so uh will you teach us how to
make sushi rolls California what's your
favorite okay let's do it
so are like sushi rolls like this
something that people would actually
make in Japan like at home actually now
we do more handle style they all have it
like the chain restaurants would have it
in Japan do you ever tell you might
favorite like thing ever is hearing you
speak just like a little bit of Japanese
yeah I wake up everyday that's what I
look forward to yeah honestly
like Kim Kim one of you guys just teach
me like a long sentence it's like I
don't care what it means okay say Hong's
I saw this Hong's I said us yeah FEMA's
avocado
yeah crab and the logo sucks at this
time ah gotcha
this is remarkable BAM boom ah yeah are
you trying to make it kind of square
square or Attic square yeah Wow okay I'm
down to try that yeah so he said what to
see ya just gotta stay me my
oh this was kind of go yeah this okay so
kind of should I put it like that no in
the middle okay you already know yeah
big crustacean hours right here load up
this time that was kind of lowly means
it's easy with yeah so the thing that
you know I don't know about me is I
loved weapons I'd know how to throw
knives what you don't ask how I'm just
obsessed with those kind of things so I
feel like me with the knife is kind of
like I feel like it's already at the
extension of my hand
planet I can't do sharp things like ever
since I cut myself like trying to shave
my pubes once and then like it was just
no good from there like their blades no
it's just that's a true story though
really yes so do you use to cut your
penis just razor Gillette Gillette yeah
you want to try both me and judges and
kind of say which one's better
yeah is that disgrace which one of us
would be better off working in your
technique-wise yes yes sure oh yeah sure
[Music]
now seems like we've made a lot we
definitely need to make more for the
party
now chef I've been eyeing that for a
while now what's going on here
that's a California's political drama
okay
can I hold on oh why they just [ __ ]
spit like that oh yeah I did not expect
to move like that
that is so crazy that's kind of seasoned
all right now I told you guys that I
could see you know yes I actually bring
the Unni
Oh shrimp sushi how about that it's
crazy because they can see us
yeah
is it dead god I've never seen like my
food being killed in front of me before
it's worth it cuz it's gonna be
delicious oh my god that's that's edible
in live there yeah Wow okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
mmm Wow
I didn't remember that it was alive
couple minutes ago yeah fantastic
all right so we are now sushi masters
and we're really good at it and I'm very
confident so now we're gonna prep for
the party but thank you very much chef -
Thank You chef and now we will continue
a legacy and why don't we all just you
know because while sushi masters now we
all just hold up our knives and you can
join in on this yeah sure we should have
posted the camera
[Music]
[Music]
impressing me
like a dress but you fit better and
wrinkle t we moved on until the devil
being a history
[Music]
[Applause]